In the US, the US sharply condemned Monday's conviction...
...of two Reuters journalists in Myanmar...
...and their seven-year prison terms for violating the country's secrecy laws.
In the Philippines, suspected Muslim militants detonated a second bomb...
...in less than a week Sunday,...
...leaving at least one person dead and 15 injured.
In China, President Xi Jinping tells African political and business leaders in Beijing...
...his country will provide an additional 60 billion dollars' worth of financing to Africa.
A massive fire has gutted Brazil's national museum...
...and destroyed over 20 million items of history,...
...leaving many distraught at the loss of priceless anthropological artifacts.
Finally, one in 18 migrants crossing the Mediterranean Sea...
...in an effort to reach Europe from Africa...
...has died in the attempt since the start of the year, the UN refugee agency says.